this video is kindly sponsored by star
trek fleet command the free to play
multiplayer open world strategy game
that's available on both ios and android
by using my link in the description
below hey 42 here black holes are
regions in space where the pull of
gravity is so strong
that nothing not even light can escape
they're the most extreme objects in the
entire universe but describing just how
awe-inspiring they are is actually kind
of difficult
they simply defy explanation in terms
that we humans can understand
take their size for instance our solar
system contains eight planets five dwarf
planets more than 200 moons and well
north of a million asteroids
that sounds like a lot of stuff right
and it is but compared to the sun
it's basically nothing
with a massive 2 million trillion
trillion kilograms
the sun makes up a staggering 99.8
of the total mass of our solar system
big
doesn't really cover it and yet the
largest black holes in existence can
reach 50 billion times the mass of our
sun if you were all powerful and a
little bored and you decided to pile
copies of the sun on top of the world's
largest set of scales at a rate of one
every second
it would take you more than 1
500 years of non-stop work to rival the
mass of the universe's biggest black
holes if that's hard to imagine allow me
to bring the scale down to human size
well rhino size in terms of mass the
largest black holes in existence are to
the sun what a rhinoceros is to a grain
of sand star trek fleet command gives
you the opportunity to engage in a story
driven star trek galaxy where you can
interact with famous characters from the
next generation the original series the
j.j abrams films discovery and more you
play in a real-time combat open world
where you can battle alongside your
allies to capture territory pool
resources and dominate the multiverse
and for a limited time if you reach
level 5 by the 10th of february 2022
you'll unlock a free origins burnham and
the shards to tear up your burnham to
rank 2. i especially love the wide range
of research trees that allows you to
specialize your fleet allowing you to
conquer the multiverse story and bag
those battle pass rewards along the way
or if you're the kind of player who
likes to go solo be sure to check out
freelancer mode where you can travel the
open world independently and play by
your own rules either way base building
space battles quality graphics and spock
i'm all in
don't forget star trek fleet command is
free to play on ios and android so be
sure to use my link in the description
below to download it today happy
trekking
black holes of this size called
supermassive or sometimes ultra massive
black holes are capable of swallowing
entire solar systems as easily as you
might accidentally swallow a fly whilst
out for an evening jog
but as mind mind-bogglingly destructive
as these intergalactic heavyweights are
recent research has suggested something
rather surprising
there may well be planets orbiting some
of the biggest meanest black holes in
the universe
lots of them
so how is that possible and more
importantly could these planets harbor
life
whilst it might seem hard to believe
that habitable planets could survive on
the fringes of these terrifying giants
supermassive black holes aren't quite
the intergalactic vacuum cleaners most
people think they are in fact the idea
that they mercilessly suck everything
around them into their gaping maws
is probably one of the biggest
misconceptions in our small corner of
the universe black holes don't suck at
all objects are pulled towards them in
exactly the same way you're currently
being pulled towards the earth assuming
you are indeed watching from earth
through gravity
so long as you don't get too close which
isn't recommended unless you like the
idea of being turned into human
spaghetti the gravitational attraction
of a black hole is exactly the same as
that of a star of the same mass if you
were to wave that magic wand of yours
and instantaneously replace the sun with
a black hole of equal mass
it wouldn't suddenly devour the earth
and all the other planets
in fact
nothing would change at all the planets
would continue to happily orbit the
black hole
as they'd previously orbited the sun of
course we'd all die slowly and horribly
as temperatures plummeted and the oceans
froze over but at least it would solve
that whole global warming thing so
there's no reason why planets couldn't
happily orbit a supermassive black hole
the question is do they
it's generally accepted that planets are
formed in the giant clouds of dust and
gas that encircle young stars over time
dust particles within these clouds which
are known as protoplanetary disks bump
into one another and if the collision
isn't too violent they stick together
over time those specks of dust become a
little ball
which becomes a rock which becomes a
boulder which eventually becomes
something called a planetesimal when the
chunk of space dust gets big enough its
own gravity begins to take over
attracting more dust and combining with
other debris and planetesimals until
eventually it's big enough to qualify as
a planet and it turns out that some
supermassive black holes are also
orbited by swirling clouds of dust and
gas
known as accretion disks
that are in many ways quite similar to
protoplanetary disks recent research
suggests that under the right conditions
planets can form within a black hole's
accretion disk in much the same way they
do around stars of course we're talking
about two very different scales here as
we've seen supermassive black holes are
much bigger than stars and so are the
clouds of dust and gas that encircle it
that means there's a lot more building
material to go around and more building
material means more planets like
a lot more
upper estimates predict that a single
supermassive black hole could form the
center of a giant black hole system
containing more than 10 000 planets well
not planets exactly for reasons that are
quite hard to rationalize it seems
scientists have decided to call planets
that orbit black holes
planets
with a bee i do wonder if any of them
have noticed that we don't call planets
that orbit stars
slanets that's going to be an awkward
meeting anyway these
planets could be strange indeed with the
largest being some three thousand times
more massive than earth that's about as
big as a planet can get before it goes
through a pokemon style evolution and
turns into a brown dwarf
okay so now for the most important part
could these colossal black hole systems
and their unbelievably huge planets
harbor life
well first a disclaimer whilst i do
consider myself to be relatively well
traveled i haven't yet made it to a
planet so it's pretty hard to say for
sure but since the release of
christopher nolan's interstellar a film
that features a planet or planets called
miller's world that orbits a fictional
supermassive black hole scientists have
begun to take a pretty keen interest in
the topic
this isn't just some fun force
experiment either the habitability of
planets could one day
literally be the difference between life
and death for our species
but i'm getting ahead of myself
when searching for life out there in the
far reaches of space
we humans tend to start by looking for
planets with surface temperatures that
could support liquid water
that's because so far as we know every
single living thing in the universe
requires liquid water to survive
or at least everything on earth seems to
we have liquid water here on our lovely
big blue marble thanks to heat from the
sun
but planets orbit cold unforgiving black
holes instead of nice cozy stars
so of course they're all just chunks of
frigid rock and ice or are they
actually probably not you see it turns
out there are a couple of other
potential sources of energy near black
holes that might just be able to provide
enough warmth for liquid water to exist
on a planet
it's never going to stop feeling stupid
saying that word is it whilst black
holes themselves emits no light it turns
out the vicinity immediately surrounding
them can be incredibly bright you've
probably already seen this now famous
picture
the first ever taken of a black hole
that glowing ring around the outside is
the black hole's accretion disk as mata
from the accretion disk is devoured by
its parent black hole it's accelerated
to
truly mind-blowing speeds as much as
half the speed of light
at that kind of pace the amount of
energy released free friction is
astonishing
if a planet happens to be the right
distance away from a supermassive black
hole the accretion disk may be able to
fulfill the same role the sun does for
us
providing enough warmth and light to
support liquid water and therefore
nurture life that sounds great on paper
but there is one small problem you see
accreting supermassive black holes are
amongst the most luminous objects in the
entire universe the largest known as
quasars can be thousands of times
brighter than the 400 billion or so
stars in the milky way
put together i'm going to say that again
because quite frankly it's insane a
single black hole can shine with the
light of thousands of galaxies quasars
can also be incredibly hot
one that goes by the snappy name of
3c273
has been measured at 10 trillion degrees
kelvin that's about 1.5 billion times
hotter than the surface of the sun so
yeah whilst an accreting supermassive
black hole could potentially provide the
warmth needed to sustain liquid water it
would probably be just as likely to melt
any nearby planets to interstellar slag
luckily not all supermassive black holes
come pre-packaged with world-ending
accretion disks and it's around these
karma giants that's another potential
ice melting energy source might come
into play but a fair warning
things are about to get seriously weird
this mystery energy is the
electromagnetic radiation left over from
the big bang otherwise known as the
cosmic microwave background the good
news is the cosmic microwave background
is the single biggest source of
radiation in the entire universe by a
very long way it can be found
literally everywhere the bad news is
it's extremely cold just a few degrees
above absolute zero the same temperature
as outer space
but here physics has a trick up its
sleeve you see as the cosmic microwave
background is pulled into a black hole's
gravity well
it becomes blue shifted
decreasing its wavelength and increasing
its energy which means the closer you
get to a black hole the hotter the
cosmic microwave background should feel
and it's possible that this weird
phenomenon could create a kind of
goldilocks zone around a black hole that
would be warm enough to support liquid
water which is great
what's a little bit less great is that
this goldilocks zone
baldilox zone
is probably dangerously close to the
black hole's point of no return the
event horizon here the pull of gravity
would be incredibly strong and the only
way for a planet to resist it would be
to orbit that black hole extremely
quickly like practically the speed of
light quickly
whether or not that's even possible is
highly debatable and even if it is
possible it brings with it a whole of a
bunch of issues thanks to the weirdness
of special relativity both very high
speeds and very strong gravity cause
time dilation they literally make time
slow down
which means that time on a planet moving
it close to the speed of light just
beyond the event horizon of a
supermassive black hole would move
incredibly slowly
potentially tens of thousands of times
more slowly than it does here on earth
that in itself isn't necessarily an
issue
time dilation is a relative effect you
only notice it if you compare the
passage of time in two different places
meaning time always feels
normal from your own perspective even if
you're experiencing extreme time
dilation but there's another less
obvious reason why time dilation on a
planet could be an issue for life
in interstellar every hour on miller's
world was the equivalent of seven years
back on earth that's a time dilation
factor of about 60 000. as you may know
it took roughly 500 million years for
life to emerge here on earth but for 500
million years to have passed on a planet
with a time dilation factor of 60 000
the universe would need to be at least
30 trillion years old and uh
it isn't
so yeah even if life could exist on the
kind of planet where the cosmic
microwave background is hot enough to
support life and that's a very big if
it probably hasn't had time to evolve
just yet the truth is whilst there's a
reasonable chance giant black hole
systems are out there exactly what they
might look like and whether they could
ever harbor life
is still very much an unknown what we
think we know so far is based on lots of
assumptions and if those assumptions
turn out to be wrong
so will our conclusions but as i've
already mentioned whether or not life
could exist on a planet isn't just idle
speculation it really could be life or
death to us humans
one day in the near future about 100
trillion years from now star formation
will end okay so not exactly the near
future anyway a hundred trillion years
from now as the stars that remain begin
to wink out one by one the universe will
go dark
when that happens we humans won't have
much choice but to head for the nearest
black hole after all black holes will be
the only place left to go
the last sources of energy in the dying
universe
whether or not we can actually survive
when we get there
is a pretty big deal okay fine maybe i'm
getting just a tiny bit ahead of myself
it's not exactly a given that our
species will make it through the next
100 trillion years even the next hundred
years to be honest but hey it's always
good to be prepared
thanks for watching